is there um
advice you can give on how to learn math
for people whether it's middle school
whether it's somebody
as an adult kind of um gave up on math
maybe early on
i actually think that these math
competition problems those school in
high school are really good
they're actually very hard so if you if
you haven't had this
kind of experience before and you grab a
middle school math competition problem
from the state level which is used to
decide who represents the state in the
country in the united states for example
those are pretty tricky and even if you
are a professional
maybe not doing mathematical things and
you're not a middle school student
you'll struggle
so i find that these things really do
teach you things but by trying to work
on these questions
is there a googleable term that you
could use for the organization
for the state competitions ah yeah so
there are a number of different ones
that are quite popular
one of them is called math counts
m-a-t-h-c-o-u-n-t-s
and that's a big tournament which
actually has a state level there's also
a math league.org
mathleaguelegue.org also has
this kind of tier the tournament
structure there's also the american math
competitions amc
8 amc also has amc 10 that's for 10th
grade and below and amc
12. these are all run by the
mathematical association of america
and these are all ways to find old
questions what about the daily
challenges that you run
what are those about we do that too but
i mean the difference was
ours isn't that one is not free so so
this i should actually probably be
careful the things that i've just
mentioned are also not free
not all of those things i mentioned just
now are free either but people can
figure out what it is
but yeah this is really nice to know
what's out there but yeah can you speak
a little bit to the daily challenges
sure sure so that's actually what we did
when um
i guess i was thinking about how would i
try to develop that skill in people if
we had the power to architect the entire
system ourselves
so that's called the daily challenge
with potion low it's not free because
that's actually how i pay for everything
else i do so that's that was the idea
but the the concept was aha now let's
invent from scratch
so if we're going to go from scratch and
we're going to use technology
what if we made every single lesson
something where first i say hey here's
an interesting question recorded of
course it's not live but it's like i say
hey here's an interesting question why
don't we think about this
but i know i know you don't know how to
do it so now you think
and a minute later a hint pops on the
screen but you still think and a minute
later a big hint pops on the screen
you still think and then finally after
the three minutes hopefully you got some
ideas you try to answer
and then suddenly there's like this
pretty extended explanation of
oh yeah so here's like multiple
different ways that you can do the
question
and by accident you also just learn this
other concept
that's what we did so is this targeted
towards middle school students
high school students it's targeted
towards middle school students with
competitions
but there's a lot of high school
students who didn't do competitions in
middle school
where they would also learn how to think
if you can see the whole concept was
can we teach people how to think how
would you do that you need to give
people the chance to
on their own invent without that kid in
the front row answering every question
in two seconds
and uh people can find it i think with
daily.
it's daily.poshando.com but if you go to
find my website
you'll be able to find it beautiful can
we zoom out a little bit
and uh so day to day week to week
month to month year to year what does
the lifelong educational process look
like
do you think for for yourself
but for for me what would you recommend
in in the world of mathematics or sort
of as opposed to studying for a test but
just like
lifelong expanding
of uh knowledge and that skill for
invention i think i often articulate
this as
can you always try to do more than you
could do in the past
yeah but that comes in many ways and
i i will say it's great if one wants to
build that with mathematics
but it's also great to use that
philosophy with all other things
in fact if i if i just think of myself i
just think what do i know now that i
didn't know a year ago or a month ago or
a week ago
and not just know but like what do i
have the capability of doing yes
and if you just have that attitude it
brings more
see the thing is there's also a habit
like it is a skill like i've been using
anki
it's an app for helps you memorize
things
and i've actually this a
few months ago started doing this daily
of
setting aside time to think about an
idea
that's outside of my work like let's say
let's pick it's all over the place by
the way but
let's say politics like gun control uh
is it good to have a lot of guns or not
in society
and just i've set aside time every day
i do at least 10 minutes but i try to do
30 where i think about a problem i kind
of outlined it for myself from scratch
from not looking anything up just
thinking about it
using common sense and i think the
practice of that is really important
it's the daily routine of it
it's the discipline of it it's not just
that
i figured something out from that
thinking about gun control
it's more that that muscle is built
too it's that thinking muscle so i'm
kind of interested in
[Music]
you know math has because especially
because
i've gotten specialized into machine
learning and because i love programming
so much
i've lost touch with math
a little bit to where i feel quite sad
about it and i
want to fix that even just not
math like pure knowledge math but math
like these middle school problems
the challenges right um
is that something you see a person be
able to do every single day kind of just
practice every single day
for years so i can give an answer to
that that gives a practical way you
could do it assuming you have kids
so you can do step one get kids
no no i'm just saying this because i'm
just thinking out loud right now
like what could i do what could i do to
suggest because what i have noticed is
that for example if you do have kids who
are in elementary school or middle
school
if you yourself go and look at those
middle school math problems
to think about interesting ways that you
can teach your elementary school or
middle school kid
it works that's what my wife did she
never did any of those contests before
but now she knows quite a lot about them
and i didn't teach her anything i don't
i don't do that
she just was messing around with them
and taught herself
all of that stuff and that had the
automatic daily i i'm always thinking
how do you make it practical right yes
and the way to make it practical
is if the the timer on the automatically
daily is that you are going to
automatically daily do something with
your own kid
yes now it feeds back okay and that
includes the whole lesson that if you
want to learn something you should teach
it
oh i strongly believe that yes i
strongly believe
that uh so i currently don't have kids
so that's uh
maybe i should just get kids to help me
with the math thing but
outside of that i i do want to do great
math into daily practice so
i'll definitely take out uh i'll
definitely check out the daily
challenges and see
because um what is it uh grant sanderson
we talked about offline
three blue one brown he he speaks to
this
as well that his videos aren't
necessarily
they don't speak to the thing that i'm
referring to which is the daily practice
they're more almost tools of inspiration
they kind of show you the beauty of a
particular
of problem in mathematics
but they're not a daily ritual and i'm
in i'm in search of that daily ritual
mathematics
it's not it's not trivial to find
but i hope i hope to find that because i
think math
gives you a perspective on the world
that enriches
everything else so i like what you said
about the daily also because that's also
one reason why i put my carnegie mellon
class online it's not every day it was
every it's every other day semester is
almost over
but the idea was i guess my philosophy
was if i'm already doing the class let's
just like put it there right
but i do know that there are people who
have been following it
who are not in my class at all who have
just been following it because
yes it's combinatorics and the value of
that
is you could you don't really need to
know calculus to follow it if that makes
sense
so it's actually something that people
could follow so again and that one's
free so
that one's just there on youtube
you